In this video, we're going to show you how you can use CI-driven scans in Burp Suite Enterprise
when you're using GitLab as your CI provider. Now to do this, you'll have already needed to
have created a user in Burp with an API key which has permissions to run CI-driven scans.
If you need help with this, you can look at our documentation pages on our website.
Now in my GitLab repository here, I have four files, but the main ones are the GitLab CI file for the pipeline,
the Burp config file for the scan configuration, and the recorded login JSON file.
Now our pipeline file just says that we're going to run our Docker container, and it points to our
configuration file for the scan, and it's also going to say to output a JUnit report file when the scan
finishes. And in this artifacts rule, we say that we're going to pull out this JUnit report file,
and then report those tests directly in the pipeline.
If we go back and look at our Burp configuration file, we can see that it points to our Enterprise
server, and we also have our API key here for authentication. If you're using a self-signed
certificate as well, you'll need to include the public key here of that certificate to prove the
authenticity of the server. If you scroll down, we have a correlation ID, which is the name that the
site will show us in the Burp console. If you don't want the site to show in the Burp console,
then you don't need to have a correlation ID. We also have the start URLs, and all of this
configuration here is the same as what we have in the Burp console. Under the reporting section,
we say that we're going to fail the build if we have a low severity issue with a firm confidence.
But all the settings here are just a snapshot of what you can set for a CI-driven scan.
On our GitHub, we have a publicly accessible repository which shows all the different settings that you
can set within a CI-driven scan. You can find it at the link that's on the screen.
Now, if we go back to GitLab and kick off a new build,
if we go to pipelines, and then we run our pipeline.
You can see here that pipeline is now starting, and if we go to our jobs,
you can see here that it's found our Burp config path and run the test.
Now, if we go to check our Burp, under Scans, we can see that our new scan has been started.
And if we go to view the site, we can see here that the site was created by CI-driven scan.
If we go to a scan which was already completed in the past,
you can see here all the different statistics of the scan as it ran, and we can see at the end here
that the job failed with exit status 1 because we reached our issue threshold here.
So if we go back to the job, and then we go to the test pane,
you can see here all the tests that were run during the scan and the ones that failed.
And if we go to view details, we can see in here the severity, confidence, host, and path of the issue,
as well as the issue detail and background, and all of the same information that you're used to seeing
within the Burp console. And that's how you run a CI-driven scan in Burp when using GitLab.
So, let's see.